[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend hinein er hat es so gewollt
robert habeck wollte vizekanzler werden
und wirtschaftsklima zukunftsminister
entscheider also bei einem thema das
zentrales wahlversprechen seiner grünen
partei war und gleichzeitig zentrale
zukunftsaufgabe für diesen planeten ist
habeck musste wissen dass er sich damit
zwischen alle stühle setzen würde
zwischen die denen es bei weitem nicht
drängend und nicht schnell genug
vorangeht und die die sorge haben dass
sie sich die neue klimaneutrale zeit
nicht leisten können also hat sich der
grüne vize kanzler heute munitioniert
mit schautafeln und charts um erst mal
eine bilanz zu ziehen es ist eine
ziemlich verheerende geworden für
harbeck hat sie den vorteil dass er die
noch seinen vorgängern zu schieben kann
ab jetzt ist er dran in einem land in
dem große pläne schon mal im kleinen
scheitern bernd band ihn
ein alptraum für robert habeck könnten
orte wie winterlingen werden hier auf
der schwäbischen alb sollten sieben
windräder entstehen herbert beach und
viele andere im ort liefen dagegen sturm
dann gab es anrufe von
grundstückseigentümern die gefragt haben
müssen wir dulden dass hier die
windräder über unserem land gehen sage
ich nein das müssen sie nicht dulden und
da hat man gemerkt in der bevölkerung
dass wir wirklich in widerstand gegen
dieses projekt vorhanden nicht über
3.700 einwände erreichten das
landratsamt irgendwann gab der betreiber
genervt auf projekt geplatzt in zukunft
könne man sich so etwas nicht mehr
leisten das ist eine der botschaften von
robert habeck heute eine andere
deutschland sei dabei die eigenen
klimaziele meilenweit zu verfehlen
wir starten nicht auf der ziellinie
sondern mit einem gehörigen rückstand im
prinzip kann man über den groben daumen
sagen wir müssen dreimal besser seien in
allen bereichen habe hat plakate
mitgebracht und die zeigen die deutsche
klimapolitik als scherbenhaufen viel zu
wenig windkraft und die letzten jahre
wurde überhaupt nicht mehr auch schon
zugebaut allgemein viel zu wenig
erneuerbare energien für so noch einmal
dieses vergab dafür noch viel zu viel
ausstoß von co2
da sind wir also und da müssen wir hin
eine kluge kommunikationsstrategie
erstmal die erwartung so ab zu denken
dass man sich um nachher nicht mehr so
leicht beschweren kann aber so
funktioniert ja klimaschutz nächste
funktion die klimagerechtigkeit nicht
aber habe ich formuliert auch vorhaben
konkret zwei prozent der landesfläche
werden für windkraft reserviert der
ausbau soll zum überragenden
öffentlichen interesse erklärt werden
das heißt etwa individueller tierschutz
steht im zweifel zurück
solaranlagen werden für gewerbliche
neubauten pflicht für private neubauten
sollen sie die regel werden und die
eeg-umlage wird ab nächstem jahr nicht
mehr über die stromrechnung bezahlt 300
euro entlastung jährlich soll das einem
durchschnittshaushalt bringen die
opposition warnt dennoch vor sozialen
unruhen angesichts stark steigender
energiepreise und die industrie mahnt
auch unternehmen bräuchten
planungssicherheit
wir müssen global wettbewerbsfähig
bleiben deutschland ist ein exportland
unser erfolg entscheidet sich bei
unseren kunden überall in der welt das
heißt wir brauchen energie zuverlässig
für die industrieunternehmen und wir
brauchen sie zu wettbewerbsfähigen
preisen
herbert beach in winterlingen stellt
sich darauf ein wieder gegen die
windräder zu kämpfen wir sind natürlich
wachsam sollte wieder ein neuer
projektierung master suchen werden wir
da sein
eines hat robert habeck heute erkennen
lassen er weiß die aufgabe wird
unendlich anstrengend und er weiß auch
winterlingen ist eigentlich überall
so genannte harbeck gunnar sievers ja
das war heute so was wie ein appell an
uns deutsche von innen gekleidet in
wohlgesetzte worte habeck style wenn man
so will sie haben gesagt das wird tief
rein gehen in gesellschaftliche
realitäten da ahnen wir was aber was
heißt das jetzt konkret für uns alle
welche belastungen kommen da auf uns zu
allgemein heißt dass wir es nur schaffen
wenn alle mitziehen die naturschutz und
umweltverbände die kommunen die
verschiedenen politikerinnen und
politiker der verschiedenen parteien
länder und bund und wir uns überbieten
wollen in hilfsbereitschaft und wenn wir
ein spiel anfangen zu spielen wir können
uns nichts wir versuchen der beste
verhinderer zu sein dann kann man sich
im ministerium auf den kopf stellen dann
wird das schiefgehen das ist natürlich
eine klasse mentalität veränderung
gegenüber dem politischen spiel und was
kommt auf uns zu mehr erneuerbare
energien mehr solarpaneele mehr
windkraft aber eben auch mehr spaß an
der sache also diese japan zu hause
tanja das auto an die eigene solaranlage
anschließen kann dann ja auch in ein
paar jahren richtig freude machen das
klingt jetzt alles ganz toll als wäre
das quasi eine eine
geschichte die spaß macht eher umgekehrt
ist es aber noch so und jetzt bringe ich
mal die andere seite mit rein dass die
chemiebranche die braucht um eben noch
klimaverträglich zu sein künftig dann
mehr strom als heute die gesamte
bundesrepublik zusammen erste
unternehmen kapitulieren jetzt bereits
vor hohen energiepreisen und wir
verbraucher ja sowieso die
situation die wir jetzt haben für die
branchen aber auch für die verbrauchern
und die verbraucher liegen daran dass
der hunger nach fossilen energien
weltweit so groß geworden ist dann
kommen nach außen politische krisen dazu
ukraine russland und dann gibt es
spekulationen aber die erneuerbaren sind
teil der lösung und je mehr hier im land
installieren um so energie unabhängiger
werden wir logischerweise im preis sieht
man es jetzt schon wenn der wind weht
wenn die sonne scheint wenn die
erneuerbaren also arbeiten dann sinken
die strompreise wenn die fossilen
energien verfeuert werden dann steigen
sie dh wenn wir die erneuerbaren
wirklich massiv ausbauen werden wir am
ende einen preiseffekt bei uns allen
haben für die verbraucher aber auch für
die unternehmen die infrastruktur ist
neu und die kostet erst einmal aber das
sind gut investierte kosten für die
unabhängigkeit und auch am ende für die
kosten
zu ostern soll es schon das erste sofort
paket geben ich habe mir jetzt immer
noch nicht richtig vorstellen können was
da auf mich als verbraucher dazu kommt
nun ostern soll der kabinettsbeschluss
sei es dann ist eben eine grobe
einschätzung aber wenn wir das wenn wir
einen kabinettsbeschluss haben das ist
ja immer der erste formale akt dann geht
es in die parlamentarischen debatten der
bundestag der bundesrat dann muss es
noch in europa notifiziert werden und
dann kommt auf sie als verbraucher oder
auf uns als bürger innen 23 dann das
resultat zu erst einmal erfreuliche
werden die eeg umlage abschaffen dh in
einem vierköpfigen haushalt sagt man
spart man ungefähr 300 euro pro jahr
eine große entlastung wir werden
allerdings auch die ausschreibungs
mengen erhöhen und das heißt dann dass
mehr flächen gefunden werden müssen für
windkraftanlagen
wir werden die möglichkeit solar strom
selbst zu nutzen deutlich erhöhen die
attraktivität von solaranlagen wird
nochmal deutlich größer werden und so
werden wir dann für sie als verbraucher
irgendwann im jahr 23 auf der autobahn
häufig fluchen weil wir hinter den
anlagen hinterherfahren die dann mit 60
kmh durch die republik transportiert
werden weil wir so viel windkraft
ausbauen und das der einzige flug
na ja ich habe schon gehört ist ja eine
umstellung wir müssen nicht drum herum
reden viele menschen finden
windkraftanlagen eine belastung eine
veränderung von natur von heimat sind
sie auch ohne frage aber auch da gibt es
antworten bisher sind gerade in vielen
regionen in ostdeutschland aber das gibt
es auch im westen windkraftanlagen immer
durch fremdkapital gebaut wurden wir
haben uns fest vorgenommen die
möglichkeit bürger energie anlagen
wieder stärker zu fördern das heißt die
anwohner selber sind eigentümer ihrer
anlage dann sind die immer noch eine
veränderung der heimat aber was macht
einen großen unterschied ob man den
gewinn selber im portemonnaie hat oder
ob ihr dann auch noch abfließt zu
irgendwelchen fremdkapitalgebern die
ganz woanders setzen warum soll man dann
einen offenen zugang zu den windparks
haben wenn man den lasst die last trägt
aber nichts davon hat das können wir
besser machen das geht alles und das ist
auch ganz klar nur dann wenn aber
milliarden private investitionen also
von unternehmen tatsächlich auch richtig
kanalisiert werden und zwar in richtung
auf grüne zukunft kanalisiert werden da
gibt es die eu richtlinien dafür vor nur
die in die eu will jetzt allerdings auch
die atomkraft als grün einstufen das
wird eine große mehrheit in europa die
steht tatsächlich dahinter für sie herr
habeck nämlich an ist das der gau haben
sie mal überlegt ob nicht die anderen
vielleicht in diesem punkt dann doch
recht haben angesichts dieser großen
klimakrise so ein bisschen frei nach dem
motto der autofahrer der auf der
falschen seite fährt und er sagt wie ein
geisterfahrer tausende ja das habe ich
überlegt und bin zu dem schluss gekommen
das ist falsch ist auf die atomkraft zu
setzen ich kann das kurz deutlich machen
wir haben in der letzten zeit in europa
drei neue atomkraftwerke im bau oder in
der zulassung in finnland in
großbritannien und in frankreich
alle sind deutlich verspätet bis zu
zweistelligen jahreszahlen 10 15 jahre
verspätet und die kosten sind immens bis
zum sechsfachen nach oben gegangen es
gibt aber ein gegenargument das kommt
interessanterweise von den finnischen
grünen ihren parteifreunden dort oben
die jetzt sich klar entschieden haben
wir sind jetzt für atomenergie eben weil
sie sagen das bringt uns an unser ziel
co2 neutral zu werden besser und
schneller und ist sozusagen das kleinere
übel sind das jetzt aus ihrer sicht
keine grünen mehr die länder haben
unterschiedliche energiepolitik das muss
man sich auch können trotzdem ich würde
also den finnischen grünen und den
französischen frankreich nicht in abrede
stellen dass sie sich für ihren weg
entschieden haben aber ich erwarte von
denen umgekehrt auch dass sie
akzeptieren dass wir uns für unseren weg
entschieden haben und das haben wir in
einem breiten parteiübergreifenden
konsens getan und noch einmal dieser weg
gibt große chancen wo gefahr ist da
wächst das rettende auch haben sie heute
hölderlin zitiert so ein großer plan
kann aber auch im kleinen schaltern und
das bleibt dann anders als der rückblick
den sie heute gemacht haben die bilanz
bei ihnen kleben ja so ist das wohl klar
kann man scheitern wenn man sich großes
vornimmt kann man scheitern aber die
alternative wäre ja sich nichts mehr
vorzunehmen aus angst dass man scheitern
könnte wer wollte in so einem land leben
und der visuelle bundesregierung haben
ich hätte kein bock in seiner regierung
minister zu sein deswegen lieber voll
ins risiko und vielleicht gelingt es ja
auch und dann können wir alle
miteinander stolz aufeinander sein sagt
der vizekanzler robert habeck herzlichen
dank für das gespräch ich danke ihnen
und
das gespräch habe aus termingründen kurz
vor dieser sendung aufgezeichnet so
hanna hat jetzt den blick auf weitere
wichtige nachrichten heute
2012 hat die bremer regierung
atomtransporte über die häfen der
hansestadt verboten doch das ist
grundgesetzwidrig das entschied nun das
bundesverfassungsgericht
die haben so stadt habe mit dem
umschlags verbot ihre
gesetzgebungskompetenz überschritten
diese lege für die friedliche nutzung
der kernenergie allein beim bund heißt
es in der begründung der karlsruher
richter
wegen der ess schweren erdrutsches im
erftstadt bei der sturzflut im juli gab
es heute razzien in nrw und thüringen
140 beamtinnen und beamte durchsuchten
büros und wohnräume laut
staatsanwaltschaft bestehe der verdacht
dass an der kiesgrube ein
hochwasserschutz fall gefehlt habe zudem
könnten böschungen unzuverlässig steil
gewesen sein ermittelt wird unter
anderem gegen den eigentümer und
verpächter des tagebaus und gegen
mitarbeiter der bezirksregierung
arnsberg
der präsident des eu-parlaments david
sony ist im alter von 65 jahren
gestorben
führende politikerinnen und politiker
reagierten betroffen auf die nachricht
und würdigten den sozialdemokraten als
leidenschaftlichen und großen europäer
in italien wasser soli vor seiner
politischen karriere als journalist und
fernsehmoderator populär vergangene
nacht war starb er in einem krankenhaus
im italienischen aviano wo er seit
dezember behandelt wurde als favorit für
seine nachfolge gilt die maltesische
christdemokraten roberta mit soll
kommende woche wird das eu-parlament ein
mäßig darüber entscheiden
nach tagelangen gewaltsamen unruhen in
kasachstan hat das parlament einen neuen
regierungschef gewählt die abgeordneten
stimmten für den bisherigen vize premier
ismailov der die regierungsgeschäfte
bereits übergangsweise geführt hatte
zudem kündigte präsident tokarev den
abzug der ausländischen truppen ab
donnerstag an ihre mission seien nahezu
beendet
die politische diskussion um eine
impfpflicht in deutschland ist eine ganz
besondere geschichte erst konnte sie
fiel nicht schnell genug kommen allen
voran der kanzler gab als ziel marke aus
ab märz das wird kaum noch klappen und
überhaupt scheint der echte elan
verflogen das thema ist in aller munde
aber so richtig konkret wird praktisch
niemand debatte
positionsbestimmung anhörung das ist
alles richtig und wichtig gerade bei so
einem thema aber es passt eben auch gut
als schlagwort um sich dahinter zu
verstecken derweil hoffen die ersten
bereits dass die gesamte debatte sich am
ende erledigen könnte nicht weil die
politik entschieden hat sondern das
virus nicole diekmann
neues jahr altes thema neue gemengelagen
berlin diskutiert weiter über die
impfpflicht spd grüne und fdp können
sich nicht einigen vor allem die
liberalen sind in dieser frage gespalten
um den ganz großen streit zu vermeiden
hoffen selbst impfpflicht befürworter
innerhalb der fdp fraktion auf die
faktische kraft von omikron und spielen
wie die grünen auf zeit dass keine
maßnahme mehr gegen diese welle sondern
die vorsorge gegen die nächste welle das
parlamentarische verfahren beginnt jetzt
und wir haben auf der einen seite den
anspruch es sehr zügig zu gestalten da
stehen wir als grüne bundestagsfraktion
immer für bereit solche verfahren zügig
zu gestalten aber wir werden sie auch
mit der notwendigen sorgfalt machen
worauf wir natürlich alle gemeinsam
hoffen ist dass wir vielleicht ich sage
das wirklich im konjunktiv in eine
situation kommen könnten in die die von
den medizinern endemische lage genannt
wird das tatsächlich sich das virus vor
stark verbreitet aber keine massen
gesundheits auswirkung mehr hat für mich
wäre es natürlich super wenn wir in eine
situation kommen könnten der eine
impfpflicht deshalb obsolet werden würde
hoffnungsträger omikron stand jetzt geht
die variante zwar als hoch infektiös
aber auch als nicht so gefährlich wie
delta dominiert omikron könnte sich
nicht nur die situation im
gesundheitswesen entspannen sondern auch
die innerhalb der ampel so das kalkül da
aber stellt sich die spd heute offen
quer koalitionsfrieden hin oder her die
behauptung die einige in den raum
stellen durch omikron lösen sich alle
probleme halte ich für gewagt diese
feststellung weil man darf das virus
nicht unterschätzen eine immunisierung
der gesellschaft und dann eine rückkehr
zu einer geglaubten normalität wird man
nicht durch diese infektion erhalten
sondern nur indem man sich impfen lässt
aber auch in der spd fraktion herrscht
ebenso wie bei den koalitionspartnern
keine hundertprozentige einigkeit
nächste tretmine für die koalitionären
sie will man dadurch entschärfen dass
man fraktionsübergreifende
gruppenanträge möglich macht
entschiedener protest aus der union cdu
und csu den fall auf in ihrer neuen
oppositionsrolle und machen druck auf
die ampel wenn man in eine impfpflicht
hinein geht dann ist das eine sache die
einen breiten demokratischen konsens
brauch und nicht eine situation wo man
dann vier gruppen anträge hat und ein
gruppenantrag sich dann irgendwo knapp
durchsetzt weil das muss von allen
demokratischen parteien dann auch
mitgetragen werden und deswegen ist es
wichtig dass die regierung das die
regierung tragenden fraktionen schnell
gespräche mit uns aufnehmen wir sind
dazu bereit
unterdessen stellte bayon textchef
charlene heute eine angepasste impfung
ab märz in aussicht
impfpflicht ja oder nein für wen ab wann
es ist eine rechnung mit vielen
variablen ergebnis völlig offen und
zu eben dieser kontroversen debatte um
die impfpflicht fragen im heute-journal
update nachher an spd-fraktionsvize dirk
wiese das ganze so gegen mitternacht
die weltgesundheitsorganisation warnt
heute vor einer omikron flutwelle die
über europa hereinbrechen wenn jetzt
nichts getan werde die zahlen für unsere
nachbarn im norden sehen bereits jetzt
sehr nach flutwelle aus
dänemark hat in der letzten woche über
140.000 neue infizierte gezählt das ist
eine inzidenz von 2000
159,6 das will sich deutschland nicht
vorstellen die dänen dagegen bleiben
vergleichsweise entspannt impfen stadt
massiv einschränken lautet die strategie
das virus akzeptieren als teil des
lebens es ist ein grundsätzlich anderer
umgang mit corona heike kruse stellt ihn
vor
die königlichen leibgarde massiert jeden
tag durch kopenhagen omikron welle hin
oder her aber das thronjubiläum der
königin wird aus virus gründen lieber
auf september verschoben und fast
überall gilt wieder 3g sowie masken
pflicht in innenräumen und im
öffentlichen nahverkehr auch die
sperrstunde ist zurück doch ängstlich
sind die dänen nicht
ich finde es okay das ist die
einschränkungen gibt das ist einfach so
damit müssen wir leben
wenn ich es kriege dann kriege ich es
und dann muss ich es hinter mich bringen
so geht es mir damit
auch immer mehr experten blicken
angesichts der niedrigen todeszahlen
gelassen in die zukunft
ich bin ziemlich sicher dass wir im
laufe des januars und februars eine
generelle immunität in der bevölkerung
von 80 bis 90 prozent aufbauen von den
allgemeinen einschränkungen können wir
uns schon in ein paar monaten vielleicht
schon ende februar verabschieden da bin
ich ziemlich optimistisch
in dänemark wird mehr getestet als in
deutschland bei jedem positiven pcr-test
die virusvariante festgestellt so kann
das infektionsgeschehen präziser
verfolgt werden auf augenhöhe mit
omikron sozusagen
80 prozent der denn sind zweifach
geimpft 54 prozent schon dreifach der
typisch dänische gemeinsinn alle ziehen
an einem strang macht eine impfpflicht
überflüssig demonstrationen gegen korona
maßnahmen die anzeige sich vertrauen der
regierung aber das heißt nicht dass sie
unkritisch und naiv werden sondern sie
haben auch nicht nur ein hohes vertrauen
die regierung sondern ins politische
system insgesamt nach schnellen starken
einschränkungen hielt die regierung das
versprechen so schnell wie möglich
wieder zu lockern denn es gilt auch das
prinzip der eigenverantwortlichkeit
dass auf der einen seite stark an den
gemeinschaftssinn appelliert wurde aber
auf der anderen seite es wenig los
stellung von menschen gab die sich aber
nicht impfen lassen wollten oder die
sich weniger an die maßnahmen gehalten
haben und das ist auch wiederum würde
ich sagen ein wichtiger punkt der
sozusagen helfen kann eine polarisierung
der gesellschaft zu vermeiden trotz
aller dänischer gelassenheit die
kliniken im land stehen schon unter
druck geplante operationen werden
abgesagt omikron verschärft noch den
schon lange akuten personalmangel hände
michelle ist schon glück sieht die
tendenz aber so aus dass die
hospitalisierung zahlen stabil sind und
sogar leicht fall mit deshalb hoffen sie
dass nicht plötzlich ruhe zahlen kommen
wir beobachten das von tag zu tag und
wir sind bereit die kapazitäten sofort
umzuschichten damit
nikon das land nicht lahmlegt hat die
regierung die quarantäne auf 48 stunden
verkürzt die meisten menschen in
dänemark sind auch damit einverstanden
ein guter schuss optimismus also da oben
im norden der dänische weg wir werden
auch da weiter berichten und hanna macht
jetzt weiter mit wirtschaft und einem
wichtigen personalwechsel
zehn jahre war jens weidmann präsident
der bundesbank heute wurde er abgelöst
von joachim nagel vor allem die hohe
inflationsrate beobachtet dieser mit
großer sorge valerie haller an der
frankfurter börse was ist vom neuen an
der spitze der bundesbank zu erwarten
nagel ist gut vernetzt promovierter
volkswirt also ein mann dem man viel
fachliche kompetenz zutraut außerdem
kennt die bundesbank sehr genau weil er
dort schon 17 jahre in leitenden
funktionen gearbeitet hat inhaltlich ist
von ihm zu erwarten dass er einen
ähnlichen kurs fährt wie sein vorgänger
gleich zum amtsantritt war nagel vor
einer erhöhten inflation da klingt er
wie sein vorgänger weidmann der die
krisenpolitik der ezb schon lange
kritisiert die anleihenkäufe die
niedrigen zinsen und das viele billige
geld im umlauf vor allem klingt nagel
ganz anders als ezb chefin lagarde die
die inflation für vorübergehend hält und
kein handlungsbedarf sieht der wechsel
fällt jedenfalls sind eine schwierige
zeit die inflation so hoch wie lange
nicht und die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung unsicher
welche macht hat dann überhaupt ein
bundesbank-präsident nun als
bundesbank-präsident ist nagel vertreter
deutschlands im rat der europäischen
zentralbank und dort mitverantwortlich
für die geldpolitik der eurozone ja und
so wie er sich bislang positioniert hat
wird er bei der ezb signalisieren dass
er schulden und inflation nicht auf die
leichte schulter nimmt im ezb-rat
orientieren sich die stimmrechte an der
wirtschaftskraft der mitgliedstaaten ja
und schon allein deswegen hat die
haltung des neuen bundesbank-präsidenten
ordentliches gewicht vielen dank valerie
nach frankfurt
alles wird teurer auch die heizkosten
und das spüren vor allem geringverdiener
die bundesregierung plant deshalb
einmalig einen heizkostenzuschuss für
wohngeldempfänger
ein ein-personen-haushalt soll demnach
135 euro bekommen bei zwei personen sind
es 175 euro kritik kommt von
verbraucherschützern sie halten den
zuschuss für zu niedrig
in den usa haben mediziner einem
menschen erfolgreich das herz eines gen
veränderten schweins eingesetzt der 57
jährige patient sei drei tage nach der
transplantation wohlauf so das klinikum
in maryland damit dass schweine herz
nicht sofort vom menschlichen körper
abgestoßen wird wurden vier schweine
gene eliminiert und sechs menschliche
gene ins genom des schweins eingefügt
dass an menschlichen spenderorganen
weltweit mangelt setzt die forschung
große hoffnung in das verpflanzen
tierischer organe
auf besondere art wird ab dieser woche
in den usa die verstorbene us
schriftstellerin und bürgerrechtlerin
maja angelo geehrt als erste schwarze
frau der geschichte ist sie nun auf der
regulären viertel dollar münze zu sehen
in den kommenden vier jahren sollen auf
den us quoten regelmäßig bedeutende
frauen geehrt werden
bigotterie und scheinheiligkeit das ist
in der politik der direkte weg ins aus
im normalfall zumindest in
demokratischen staaten wir penetrant
wasser predigt und dabei selbst wein
trinkt strapaziert die geduld der wähler
irgendwann zu sehr für boris johnson
galt die regel nicht der britische
premierminister hat affären überstanden
die für andere das sichere ende bedeutet
hätten aber dieses motto hier könnte ihm
jetzt zum verhängnis werden be my baby
bringt euren eigenen sucht die einladung
zu einer feuchtfröhlichen gartenparty in
abatan downing street zum schlechtest
möglichen zeitpunkt aus london heute
abend ja in hallein
es war ziemlich warm und sonnig in
großbritannien im mai vorletzten jahres
ein ganz schöner kontrast zu den
düsteren zeiten damals mitten in der
ersten welle mit vielen toten lockt
downs und streng einschränkungen beim
sozialen umgang
alles hängt jetzt von uns allen ab die
maßnahmen zu befolgen
strafen geben für all jene die die
regeln brechen
dieser werbeclip der regierung macht
deutlich mit jemandem der nicht dem
eigenen haushalt angehörte durfte man
sich zu dieser zeit nur draußen an einem
öffentlichen ort treffen nicht mal im
eigenen garten und nur mit einer person
und was geschah in der downing street am
20 mai lud martin renn als boris johnson
privatsekretär per e-mail 100
mitarbeiter des regierungssitzes zu
drinks im garten ein um in diesen
anstrengenden zeiten das schöne wetter
auszunutzen wie er schrieb alkohol bitte
selbst mitbringen über 30 km laut
augenzeugen auch der premierminister und
seine frau
dies ist nicht die erste party in
pandemie zeiten die den premier in
bedrängnis bringt da waren diverse
weihnachtsfeiern und diese zusammenkunft
bei wein und käse ebenfalls im garten
der downing street die
verteidigungslinie es handelte sich um
arbeitstreffen ist ziemlich dünn wenn
alkoholisches getrunken wird das weiß
auch die opposition
ich finde er sollte gehen dies lässt
sich nicht entschuldigen boris johnson
ist für seinen job nicht geeignet das
vertrauen der bevölkerung verloren mit
seinen lügen täuschung dem brechen
seiner eigenen regeln
auch in der eigenen partei verliert
johnson nach einer ganzen serie von
pannen fehlentscheidungen und
kehrtwenden zusehends an rückhalt
die vorstellung dass dieselben leute die
uns all die einschränkungen auferlegten
zur selben zeit im garten einen gin
tonic schwirrten ist schlicht nicht zu
rechtfertigen
johnson ist der premier der die
schlagzeilen liebt jetzt sind es woche
für woche fast nur noch negative und
richtig unangenehm wird es wenn selbst
jene briten die dem lustigen boris
bisher alles durchgehen ließen sich von
ihm abwenden
sagt boris eigentlich aber ich bin sehr
enttäuscht über diese sache
wegen dieser angelegenheit glaube ich
ihm jetzt einfach nichts mehr selbst
wenn es um corona geht ich glaube es
sind alles lügen
gefragt ob er selbst bei der party
zugegen war verwaist johnson auf
laufende ermittlungen
all dies ist gegenstand der untersuchung
von
wie schwer doch manchmal ein einfaches
ja oder nein fallen kann
die untersuchende beamtin wird ihre
ergebnisse demnächst vorlegen dann wird
sich zeigen ob dies nicht eine feier ein
skandal zu viel gewesen ist für boris
johnson irgendwann ist die party auch
mal vorbei
interessant auch dass die londoner
polizei jetzt erklärt sie prüfe mögliche
verstöße gegen lockdown vorschriften am
regierungssitz dem ort der vor
überwachungskameras nur so strotzt denn
die polizei rund um die uhr besser im
blick hat haben sollte als jeden anderen
im land
das war unser heute-journal angebot für
sie an diesem dienstag und um kurz vor
mitternacht meldet sich dann hier nah
sagte mir mit unserem heute-journal
update von uns beiden und dem gesamten
team für sie einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
ein schöner abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die umfangreiche
hochdruckbrücke wird vorübergehend
gestört von einer front die etwas regen
und auch etwas schnee mit bringt das
wandert allmählich richtung südosten
aber das wird nicht viel sein es wird
hauptsächlich schneegriesel oder
sprühregen sein schauen in die nacht und
da wird es glatt durch überfrierende
nässe aber auch durch einige
regentropfen die mit der front erahnen
ansonsten im süden auch überfrierende
nässe möglich bei nebel ansonsten klart
es auf und die temperaturen gehen weit
zurück in den keller minus 14 grad an
den alpen bilder im nordwesten hier
richtung nordsee bei temperaturen von
plus 2 grad morgen tagesverlauf ziehen
die wolken weiter richtung mitte ein
paar flocken und etwas regen es durchaus
möglich hinter der front lockert es auf
die sonne zeigt sich mal im süden den
ganzen tag hier scheint die sonne länger
in der mitte allerdings halten sich die
wolken auch längere zeit und es ist
recht hübsch bei höchsten temperaturen
von minus zwei grad am alpenrand hier
also generell im südosten teils
dauerfrost frostfrei nach nordwesten hin
mit plus 7 grad am mildesten an der
nordsee sonst gibt es auch in den
nächsten tagen zum beispiel am
donnerstag im südwesten deutschlands bei
minus ein bis plus acht grad am freitag
gibt sogar dann im gesamten süden sonne
und das bei minus 1 bis 8 also ähnlichen
temperaturen ein schöner abend